hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
with Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
finally hitting PlayStation Plus I
thought now is the right time to look
back at all the Easter eggs Secrets
references and the weird and wonderful
cutscenes which are surprisingly
miserable during a typical playthrough
I've put together 50 in total but I'm
sure there are so many more hidden
secrets and nods to pop culture which I
am missing so please do me a favor and
write them in the comments and receive
the praise that you deserve this video
does contain one or two mild spoilers
but nothing which will ruin the complex
storyline of Metal Gear Solid okay let's
do this in the game's prologue awakening
the first Easter Egg breaks the fourth
wall once snake manages to get to his
feet keep an eye on the noticeboard and
see the Kojima Productions poster used
in real life at the 2013 game developers
conference or GDC if you prefer this was
used to recruit devs for the Tokyo and
LA Metal Gear Solid teams a little more
product placement can be seen during
mission one it's a little hard to spot
but the glass is worn by revolver ocelot
our in fact donned with the Metal Gear
Solid 5 logo I'm sure you know this
already but press r3 to zoom in during
the cutscenes pretty cool the new
companion system allows you to take
along a horse a sniper and even a dog on
each of your missions once you develop a
strong enough bond with each buddy your
interactions will subtly change D Haas
will one day feel so comfortable with
you that he'll drop Braun bullets on
command by the way my girlfriend walked
in on me capturing this footage it was
awkward but she happens I supposed the
only use I can find for horse turd is to
cover the road and cause vehicles to
lose control
another companion d-dog RDD for short
must be found in the open world the
easiest way to find her is right at the
start of mission for using this landing
zone have a quick scout around and this
little crazy [ __ ] will be there only
one thing to do now Bolton the little
bugger keep revisiting home base and
you'll see didi grow from a pup into an
adult
once your bond is high enough you'll be
able to pet her in the field oh and
should you be away from home for too
long she'll be ecstatic to see you on
your return and then we come to quiet
I'm sure you've already figured out the
only way to make her your partner in
crime is to keep your finger off the
trigger at the end of mission 11 once
your bond with quiet is high enough
she will poop on commands in her no she
won't she won't do that she does things
far more awkward such as provocatively
move around the ACC to look or not to
look is your decision she does more far
worse and weird things but I'll get to
those very soon but while we're here in
the helicopter press the r3 button and
look in the windows reflection it's a
little easier to do this at night but
you should be able to make out the
avatar you created right at the start of
the game extremely subtle but brilliant
I'm sure you'll agree if you choose to
run the extreme version of the quiet
sniper fight which is actually mission
40 you should notice quiets change in a
tire the eagle-eyed Metal Gear Solid
fans will notice she's in fact wearing
sniper wolf's costume from the original
Metal Gear Solid game if you manage to
beat her then you are now able to
research the alternative costume and
assign it to quiet for every mission by
the way on extreme difficulty she will
avoid supply drops to the head but she
has no answer for an aerial bombardment
another reference to previous Metal Gear
Solid games occurs during Miller's
rescue in mission 1
once you've returned his famous
sunglasses he'll ask you for proof you
are in fact the real snake it is
important that you're ready to press
triangle when he asks the questions as
the prompt does not show up in game
I've been waiting 9 years to hear kept
you waiting huh save for our time sake
kept you waiting
it's really you snake all these years
without you I knew this day would come
those who know Metal Gear Solid will
know that snake and the whole Metal Gear
Solid Development team actually are
notorious for making people wait and
it's kind of a catchphrase these days
what took you so long kept you waiting
man kept you waiting huh that guy always
keeps you waiting kept you waiting huh
let's go back to mother base and you'll
notice the occasional orange poster
warning of construction work stand here
too long and well suppose you will want
it also works with the nearby NPC so
fill your boots on your birthday you'll
be summoned back to mother base for what
looks like an invasion but in fact it's
a birthday party in your honor
[Music]
happy birthday Vegas I stay
[Music]
is this a legitimate birthday song
because it's simply terrible I guess
happy birthday to you must have been
copy written the birthday surprises
continue if you have quiet in your
employee as she kindly writes hbd with
an assault rifle so romantic I'm not
completely certain but hbd must
represent happy birthday right
all right so now is the right time to
show you what happens when snake and
quiet earn a 100 percent bond picture
the scene you've been on a sweaty
mission for days it's raining but
finally you're back
oh then suddenly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know about you but that made me
feel so awkward anyone else
there's more of quiets antics coming up
soon but in the meantime let's look at
book and film references in Metal Gear
Solid 5 there are a whole heap of
references to the 1984 novel about a
totalitarian state written by British
writer George Orwell back in 1949 don't
worry if you're not a fan of reading
there's a film version if you ever get
the urge in Metal Gear Solid 5 you'll
notice big boss is watching you posters
scattered around mother base these are
taken from 1984 and the theory of
propaganda rather that big brother is
always watching every little thing you
do that's also where the TV show gets
its title if you are a reality TV fun
other references to the 1984 novel come
in the shape of two plus two equals five
at this point I'm certain you've already
tried to shoot us a lot with the
tranquilizer gun and found he says a few
weird things this one in particular is
in reference to Winston being tortured
and slowly being broken down to think
how the state want him to really quite
harrowing so let's not dwell on these oh
and the room where the torture scene
takes place it's room 101 which is also
the name of the torture room in the
phantom pain and to bring the 1984
references to an end Metal Gear Solid 5
begins in the year you guessed it 1984
have you ever read Lord of the Flies by
William Golding maybe you were forced at
school or what about the film adaptation
well the similarities between Eli's
troop of child soldiers in Metal Gear
Solid 5 and Jax hunters in Lord of the
Flies are quite impressive in the Lord
of the Flies a group of English lads are
stranded on an island without any adults
they are in fear of the islands monster
which they make offerings to usually
through slaughtering pigs and hogs and
attaching their heads to sticks and
stuffs
[Music]
well that's here in Metal Gear Solid 5 -
and the conch shell you'll see on Eli
skip well that's another reference to
the Lord of the Flies and the tool used
to bring the children together which
slowly became a symbol of power held by
the leaders whoever holds the conch gets
to speak when you finally fight they
like to take a moment to shoot the pig
on the platter nearby you'll be rewarded
with this sound
pointless but who said Easter eggs have
to have a point yet another parallel to
the Lord of the Flies is the hint that
Eli killed a fellow child soldier named
Ralph we don't see it but we are
notified over comms
a pile of steel pipes gave way for us
one of the kids a boy named Ralph they
tell me he died instantly
I should have been keeping an eye on
them somehow pipes gave way and he was
crushed to death in Lord of the Flies
Ralph is a leading character who fights
with Jack he survives until the end but
another potential leader piggy is
crushed to death by his rivals but this
time it isn't pipes it's a boulder
one final not to The Lord of the Flies
would have been in the unfinished
mission fifty-one called kingdom of the
Flies and it would have brought closure
to the story of Eli and the child
soldiers but for whatever reason we will
never get to play it
such a shame shortly after the release
of Metal Gear Solid 5 Hideo Kojima the
game's director left Konami which
slightly sees the end of the Metal Gear
franchise in the way we know it luckily
for us Kojima is in the game thanks to a
side operation in which we rescue a VIP
and the first thing he says what a goose
snake you really need to rectify this
reputation it's getting too far another
developer that can be found in the
phantom pain is during the unlucky dog
mission his name is yang tan
he speaks English Chinese and Japanese
and is a born boaster also his stat says
in real life he was a level designer on
Metal Gear Solid 5
speaking of Kojima and his crew another
video game has multiple references in
the phantom pain silent hill's
sadly due to Kojima's departure this
game has been canned
if you don't know silent hill's was
going to be a first-person horror game
that Resident Evil 7 looks like it was
heavily based on the during episode 20
are from free roam if you prefer in the
area around gumbo Industrial Zone a
radio will be playing a spooky sounding
message
this is taken directly from the PT demo
of silent hill's the day of the crime
the father went to the trunk of his car
retrieved the rifle and shot his wife as
she was cleaning up the kitchen after
lunch as to is a cassette playing music
just down the road from the last Easter
Egg this tape plays music from silent
Hills and also the name of the cassette
2 0 4 8 16 was an important element in
the horror demo some of the eerie sounds
in silent Hills can be heard at night in
the phantom pain the ideal location
seems to be de Chartres Gokul I sorry if
I said that wrong and sounds like the
lighting fittings from the hallway
an early demo version of the phantom
pain had blow up decoys in the shape of
a ghost which turned out to be Lisa from
silent Hills my god that demo was scary
let's get back to more random actions by
quiet going to visit her in her cell
you'll see her showering keep that in
mind for later the cell also plays music
randomly come at the right time and
she'll be listening to the Snake Eater
title track from Metal Gear Solid 3
[Music]
this was created to sound directly like
a James Bond theme it's actually better
than many plastic bong songs in my
humble opinion of course there's a few
more James Bond references to find with
the return of the tuxedo from the
original mgs sadly at the time of
writing this this was a DLC option that
required real money to unlock have you
ever watched Goldfinger no Goldfinger
not Goldmember one of the super badass
things Goldfinger does is kill people
with gold paint he calls them his Golden
Girls well in mgs 5 quiet can be painted
from head to toe in gold paint but don't
worry too much she can't die in this
form the phantom pain is also filled
with many costume options some seem very
random but others are a nod to the MGS
series completing all campaign missions
with an s-rank rewards the player with
Rhydon from mgs for the cyborg ninja
from Metal Gear Solid 1 is here too and
even the ps1 pixelated version of snake
is here for your delights quiet kin
where the boss is sneaking suit from
mgs3 but again that's paid DLC so let's
not count that once you've finally been
given the codename big boss you can
develop the leather jacket which the
description links to the man who sold
the world both are likely references to
David Bowie and the leather jacket look
he was renowned for in the 80s his song
the man who saw the world was used in
the intro for the game and the Diamond
Dogs we are all part of is yet another
reference to a Bowie classic still with
me
let's perk things back up by visiting
quiet again if you return to home base
after a few in-game days have passed you
will absolutely stink and because it
implies everyone's happy to see you but
not so happy to smell you resulting in
Ocelot throwing a bucket of water in
your face but this can be stopped if
you've been working alongside quiet and
you have a strong enough bond with her
she'll step in front and stop Ocelot use
and this is where it gets weird
instead she will invite you to shower
with her while the staff ogle the pair
of you how on earth do I tell her I just
want to be friends still on board mother
base once you've recovered the a iPod go
have a listen to it over on the R&D deck
it'll say many things most of which are
related to Metal Gear Solid 3 such as
multiple references to the boss
snakes commanding officer in snake Eater
if you didn't play that game don't worry
shoot the pot and we'll tell you about
pie instead two five or six threes
eight or even train routes around Japan
there's a nod to the television series
the six million dollar man in the
phantom page with the sonic sound snaked
bionic arm gives off when using the
sonar or a running punch directly uses
the superhuman sound from the TV show
Colonel Steve Austin no not that one was
also a cyborg a theme that runs
throughout the Metal Gear Solid series
while we're here let's shoot Ocelot
again
the lull a Lulla low as a secret code
name for the Patriots an organization
controlling the world within Metal Gear
Solid games what a stupid name but I
quite like saying halal lol Oh moving on
if you are having a tough time in a
mission you can die three times quickly
and be gifted the chicken hat this
little beaut will make soldiers laugh
uncontrollably if they spot you it does
make the game slightly easier but the
ridicule isn't worth it is it if you die
yet again wearing the chicken hat you'll
unlock the little chicken hat also known
as the eggshell hat this one will make
bad guys completely ignore you
and forget you were there the minute you
pass it makes the game so easy it's
ridiculous but as an accessory is the
height of fashion well we did it so
there you go there's 50 Easter eggs
secret random events and the strangest
actions of a lady sniper if you've
enjoyed this please give us a like if
this took a staggering amount of time to
put together I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]